hey guys Pete here this is gonna be my
recap and review for mr. robot season 3
episode 1 called power saver mode and it
was pretty good all the way around
before I get started and jump into it I
just want to mention something that's
been bugging me
they must have handed out the season to
quite a few people and they wrote about
it in a spoiler-free way of course but
this is general idea that the series
needed to get back on track and I just
don't think that's really a good
description I know a lot of people
didn't like season 2 as much but I don't
think that it was bad by any I mean I
didn't dislike it I actually like it
better whenever you go back and watch
it's a lot thicker there's a lot more to
it and it's not just about Elliott and
whether people liked it or didn't like
it to say that it was bad or a sophomore
slump is really just kind of missing the
point I think but anyways that's the
general consensus that the series is
back and you know what I hope here is
that season 3 is not like season 1 that
season 3 is like season 3 I have
confidence that the show is gonna
continue to grow and get better so
there's no need for it to regress for me
anyways season 3 episode 1 was good I'm
not sure if it will totally satiate
those people who didn't like season 2 I
don't think it's a complete callback to
the first season but what it did have
was some structure and it did lay things
out pretty clearly so we're not left to
wonder about too much at the end of this
episode which I think will be enjoyable
for the large heart of the audience
it starts out not where it left off at
the end of season 2 but slightly before
that in other words instead of finding
out what happened after Elliott got shot
we go back a little bit so we meet Bobby
Cannavale A's his character Irving he's
at the red wheelbarrow BBQ it's a pretty
good beginning I enjoy this it's almost
like if he didn't have the Bluetooth in
his ear that we wouldn't know what era
it was based on him and the way he looks
and the car he drives and everything of
course he has a interesting
back-and-forth with the girl at the
counter he has gone there so
many times he's gotten his punch card
punched enough to get a free shake and
he gets into it with her about how he
should be able to get it right then
instead of on his next visit before that
goes on too long we see he gets a call
through his earpiece we hear him say is
he dead and we realized that he's going
to where Elliot was just shot by Tyrell
that he's talking to Tyrell we see that
he doesn't really get upset he doesn't
really do anything except sort of act in
a professional way and it leads to him
being a fixer we learned that he is a
fixer he has connections with whiterose
directly--
and therefore the dark army so that's
who urban is they've been teasing him
throughout the promotional stuff for
season 3 after he heads back we go over
to what I imagine is the Washington
Township plan it's definitely a nuclear
facility there's an interesting exchange
where a scientist is walking down the
hall and he's talking about the idea of
parallel universes he says how many
copies of ourselves exist and that's
obviously funny when you relate it to
Elliot whiterose and everyone else in
this show but mainly those two it also
calls back to what White Rose was
telling Dom who we didn't see in this
episode at all Dom we don't know where
the FBI is except for we think that they
were following Elliot and Darlene later
so white roses they're at the plant
she's in her mr. Jiang makeup you know
if she looks like a guy the guy who
works for the Chinese government her
aide asked her to let him go through on
face 2 saying that he's more than
capable and White Rose explains why
that's not what they're gonna do she
talks about Elliot how time presented
them with him right when they needed him
and what's really valuable is not as
hacking ability as far as what she says
here but his unadulterated focused rage
now is she talking about
Elliot himself or is she talking about
mr. robot or does that just mean that in
tandem they have that going on and this
makes a lot more sense towards the end
of the episode but at this point we
don't know anything about that this
blackout is pretty involved throughout
the whole episode at the Washington
Township plant or whatever nuclear
facility they're at they have backup
generators but we also see after they're
talking we see things pull out and we
see what looks to me like the it looks
like the Large Hadron Collider to me I
don't really know enough about that but
the general consensus is is that this
since about time travel and with the
multiverse thing and everything else
like I came away from this episode
thinking that SML was basically throwing
out red herrings I could totally be
wrong of course but it seemed heavy
handed to me if that's the case like
there's where's the mystery in it maybe
it'll come out later but it seemed a
little too direct in my mind when I
watched at this time the last thing we
learned in that sequence between
Minister Zhang and his assistant or her
assistant was that Elliot they expected
Elliot will give his life for the
company just as his father did who
actually worked on this project before
he died so everybody knew Elliot wasn't
dead we see him wake up and we see that
Angela is there like she said she wanted
to be he's been there for about a week I
think she said six days exactly and
she's taking care of him there in her
apartment she doesn't really honest with
him about how she got there we know she
met with White Rose and she doesn't
mention that part at all Elliot wants to
leave he has to stop Stace - he says and
he goes but not before he sort of
explains what he's out to accomplish to
her he can't find tyrell and the face to
set up it's not there anymore he ends up
going back to his apartment and he finds
Darlene there he finds out that Cisco's
dead Darlene isn't very happy with him
one that he worked with Tyrell she
doesn't know what's going on with that
and then he doesn't really care much or
he isn't focused on what's going on with
her which she feels like her life's in
danger she ends up playing to help him
stop phase two after he explains that it
wasn't him he basically screams that
and we don't know what Darlene thinks
about all this he's blaming mr. robot
obviously but where she's at on that is
not really clear except for she's gonna
go along with him there is no internet
so they go to this club it's a hackers
club I guess you could call it it seems
to be called 1984 that spray-painted on
the wall there's an interesting moment
where he talks to us about a mute button
where he kind of mutes out all the sound
but then Darlene comes back in and
explains that they can't get on a
terminal so he basically has to win this
hacking competition that's going on CTF
and yeah he does that with no problem so
I don't know what the technical aspects
of that was it seemed a little bit too
simple for me but I guess it just shows
that he really is a brilliant person
despite all of his obvious shortcoming
anyways the dark armies there they get
exported out and we meet Irving again as
he takes them away from the scene and
explains that the FBI is following them
he uses a he uses an exploit far as I
can tell he calls them up and gives them
a detective's ID and the VIN number on
the car that's behind them after looking
it up and they're able to have them shut
it down so they get away
I don't know how probable that is OnStar
was a you know had ability to takeover
vehicles and I've seen that in other
things but I don't know anything else
about it really
it was interesting though no he never
even had to speed up or do anything he
just talked on the Bluetooth once again
they go to the red wheelbarrow again
he's still pretty well obsessed with his
punch card but Elliott is like well I'm
gonna call this whole thing off and
everything turns out to be a pretty
great character I mean they introduced a
new character at the beginning of each
season it seems like and this one's a
good one he's methodical compared to
everybody else that we see you know he
doesn't there's no emotion or anything
he weighs what Elliott says he explains
his side of things that this boss isn't
gonna be happy and then he just leaves
before he does that though he does say
in a threatening way
we could put that bullet right back
inside of you the one we took out of you
but that's really it and then Eliot goes
into a dream where he has to reconcile
with what actually happened it's fairly
interesting when I lost it the first
time if I thought that he was just
walking I thought it was a little bit
wasn't the strongest scene but then as a
dream sequence I guess it worked
what he said was good the entire time
but it was just sort of strange the way
he was walking around and seeing things
the big takeaway of course is that he's
going to try to undo what he's done he
feels responsible and everything seems
to be going Elliott's way which is a
definite red flag for us as viewers and
we know that something's gonna change
that of course he mentions that mr.
robot feels gone like he doesn't feel
that he's there and that's where things
get kind of interesting for me but we
get to that in a minute my favorite part
of his little dialogue was that 5/9
didn't get rid of the invisible hand it
turned it into a fist that punched us in
the day which was a good laughs but also
pretty good explanation and you know I
think people who are into economics if
you would have thrown Elliot's plan in
front of them they would have mentioned
that this is exactly kind of how it
would have turned out Eliot of course
didn't look that far into things and
they got where they are there's a bit of
Trump parity here and a little bit of
satire related to that it's strange
though because you know it's 2015 in the
show time hasn't really moved forward
and we kind of already know how that
Trump thing is gonna end so it's
interesting to see how they continue to
add that in there like the entirety of
the show should wrap up before the 2016
race really kicks off and all that so he
goes back to Angela and Angela throws
out some more what felt like red herring
stuff to me about time travel she
mentions what if there was a way to go
back and fix it fix it all even their
parents dying and I don't know it just
didn't hold up for me as like a
plausible direction for the show to go
in is it possible that White Rose might
have said something to that effect that
never will come to light sure I mean I
don't know is it possible that it's
white roses long-term goal well he's
said he hacks time and hacking time
through time-travel sure would be the
ultimate time hack but I don't know I
have to think about that longer it just
doesn't seem I don't know it just
doesn't seem where things have been
going anyways we we did see this at the
end of season two with threatenin Mobley
they seem like they might have an idea
on how to at least reverse the hack if
not anything else so we have to figure
that Elliott will be going in that
direction rather than somewhere else we
get a little bit of an idea of what
Angela's motivation is in that way we
find out that she's not totally honest
she's more involved and more complicit
in what's happening now and that she's
also using Elliott and his condition
against him we find all this out in the
scene after he falls asleep or she comes
out and she finds mr. robot there
completely independent of Elliott and I
don't mean like bodily independent he's
still Elliott's body but there's not the
normal push and pull when we see mr.
robot most of the time he's right there
talking to Elliott now we have seen him
in season 1 and season 2 do things on
his own accord but those seem more like
exceptions than the rule here he seems
to have his own agenda and is able to
operate just as we imagined he must have
during those three days that Elliott
can't remember in other words we found
out what happens whenever Elliott loses
time mr. robot takes control and at
least right now Elliott doesn't seem
capable of understanding when that's
happening so if at the end of season two
we thought maybe Elliott was taking
control back it seems to be the opposite
really perhaps mr. robot has just gotten
better at going underneath and around
Elliott than he used to be what's
interesting here is that Angela can tell
the difference Tyrell obviously could
not tell the difference whenever he gets
back to seeing Elliott face to face and
yeah the biggest thing of all is that
Angela doesn't consider mr. robot a
friend but she understands what he is I
guess which is a daemon apparently like
he's always running in the back
crown-like we saw earlier in season one
when we got that definition and she's
willing to partner with that side of
Elliot take advantage of his situation
to further her own agenda so it's very
interesting it's a good start
I'm interested to see where it all leads
for what it's worth most everything that
I have read that was spoiler free says
that the whole seasons good of the
people who saw the whole season yeah I
think that's naturally what I was
expecting the whole time I feel like
this show will evolve and there's a
beginning a middle and an end I think
Sam SML is pretty good at delivering the
moments most of the criticism of season
2 kind of got washed away by the end I
mean I think most people would agree
that the season wrapped up in a very
satisfying way even if they didn't like
the longer character-building episodes
now we have more players we didn't even
see like I said we didn't even see Dom
in this episode and that's a whole
nother thing that got fleshed out last
season no idea what's going on with
trenton Mobley or Leon or any of that
but we do know what Angela is trying to
do we do know mr. robot is her
accomplice and that she is working with
Elliot to keep him in the dark about
what those two are doing plus we have
the new fixer Irving we have Tyrell
there who is been pounding the pavement
the whole time to get phase 2 going and
it looks like White Rose is gonna get
her way and get this thing pushed
through I don't know about you guys but
I'm excited to see where it goes
so please leave any questions thoughts
comments you have in the comments there
please like the video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already I'll be doing this all
season long I'm going to do some bonus
videos in between episodes too plus I'm
still working on my re-watch videos that
are gonna be coming out every so often
so yeah definitely follow along
subscribe and turn on notifications plus
you can find me on Twitter Instagram and
Facebook thanks for watching guys I'll
talk to you soon